[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con que hoy
realizamos de manera excepcional desde
el festival de cannes en la costa azul
francesa y me encuentro con la directora
del cine chileno dominga sotomayor que
tal domínguez bien y tu ella participa
con una película colectiva como parte de
la selección oficial pero fuera de
competencia el año de la tormenta
interminable una película en que se
invitó a los realizadores a graficar en
imágenes lo que ha sido este año en
pandemia
dominga cuéntanos cómo es haber
participado en esta película cómo se da
la oportunidad para ti y bueno como éste
están sintiendo aquí en este festival de
cannes sin nació súper especial esta
beca sobre todo después de dos años sin
ir al cine sin salir de chile como casio
una un regalo muy bonito este festival
como para cargarse de energía y de ganas
de hacer películas
me invitara el año pasado a hacer este
proyecto estaba inspirado los
productores de eeuu está inspirado en
jaafar panahi que ya estaba confirmado
como uno de los cortometrajes y nada fue
un proyecto muy espontáneo había que
hacer con un presupuesto muy chiquitito
un corto en el país de cada uno
respetando la cuarentena y las reglas de
cada país estábamos en plena pandemia en
chile después del estallido todos
encerrados era como un tiempo súper
extraño teníamos un permiso a la semana
para salir dos horas y decidí hacer este
corto con mi amigo mi hermana que son
actrices entonces básicamente filme en
la casa de mi mamá con mi mamá y con mi
hermana durante parte fin de semana me
ayudaron un par de amigos pero fue así
muy precario entonces más bonito todavía
que esta película tan chiquitita haya
quedado como parte de este largo que
estoy súper contenta de ser parte porque
admiro mucho a los otros directores
increíbles muy importantes como viajar
panahi
y otros directores estadounidenses cuál
fue la consigna que les dieron ustedes a
nivel por ejemplo de temática y también
técnica
y vemos que por ejemplo el corto de
panahi con el que comienza la película
está el commit ultra presente el acierto
de su madre y como las personas adultas
mayores envidio también la pandemia que
un poco a veces chocante con mucho miedo
y en cambio está justamente el de
apichatpong weerasethakul que es un poco
más abstracto un poco en la línea de su
cine cuáles fueron esas consignas claves
que era un proyecto muy abierto muy
libre las únicas reglas era que fuera
como en el tiempo presente que no nos
rompiera la cuarentena y que
usar equipos que no tenían su casa como
que lo podías como arrendar equipo
entonces eso creo que lo lindo de la
película que terminan siendo como siete
visiones muy distintas todos los cortos
son muy distintos como muy autorales de
distintas partes del mundo pero
conectados por esta crisis mundial y yo
creo que son como finalmente la película
una especie como de documento de lo que
estaba pasando el año pasado no siento
que es una película sobre él ni tampoco
fue la regla pero si de una película
cruzada por eso y creo que va a ser
importante más adelante también ayer
viéndola por primera vez porque no la
había visto pensaba qué va a pasar en 20
años cuando miremos esta película como
para atrás como que es muy para mí es
muy emocionante acordarme desde esos
tiempos de mucha incertidumbre ahora
estamos un poco más tranquilos como que
hay vacuna hay un poco de esperanza pero
el año pasado fue súper difícil creo que
fue una tormenta personal emocional
colectiva y que esta película como que
captura bueno voy abierta en tu caso tú
dices bueno en tu historia no ser toda
tu hermana tiene un hijo eso esto es
verídico entonces la es la casa de tu
mamá bueno yo hizo una ficción
recolectando cosas que estaban pasando
fue como ir al trabajo sin y cine parte
de lo que tengo cerca y aquí el director
de fotos que siempre trabajó con él se
llama inti briones y yo lo llamé y le
pregunté inti me podía ayudar en este
nuevo proyecto mejor estoy por tener una
hija no puedo salir de mi casa nunca
elige antes y me ayudó como por su y
después también fue una vez al rodaje me
ayudó como a manejar la cámara dice la
cámara yo sola por primera vez entonces
mezcle todo dije puedo ver a mi mamá ya
mi hermana venir a ver a esta guagua que
nació resident y como me gustaba esta
idea como de tenerlas a ellas aisladas
en el cerro como empeñado y bajando a
esta ciudad suspendida con una pandemia
suspendida que fue algo súper violento
igual como que nos encerraron después
del estallido y los carabineros pintaron
los muros o sea como que aquí no pasaba
nada y yo creo que
la de carabineros que es la policía en
la policía chilena y vienes a este
festival de cannes una primera vez en
realidad tienes una carrera estás
empezando en el cine o sea lleva unos
buenos años pero eres muy joven todavía
como realizadora en hazte un premio en
rotterdam con su primer largometraje
luego con tu tercer largometraje
demasiado tarde para morir joven ganaste
el premio de locarno como directora como
realizador a qué importancia tienen para
ti los festivales como éste y cómo lo
hace para llegar hasta aquí supo que no
es fácil
nada es lindo estar en este festival
creo que los festivales como que
celebran el cine nos hacen acordarnos de
lo importante que es ver películas
colectivamente ha sido como muy bonito
esta es la película más chica que he
hecho en mi vida y es la primera vez que
estoy en cannes como directora había
estado como productora pues también es
bonito que este corto sea parte de este
festival es como una linda sorpresa y
finalmente del cine chileno no está muy
presente en este festival él sólo está
contigo pero está pasando muy buen
momento a nivel internacional de
reconocimiento sobre todo porque la
presencia chilena ha sido tan pobre en
este stand no sé bueno también se han
hecho menos cosas hay muchas películas
productos
pero ha sido un tiempo super difícil
para el cine chileno yo creo que la
pandemia ha mostrado la fragilidad de
los trabajadores de la cultura creo que
es como un tiempo de revisarlo me siento
responsable estar acá como de los pocos
chilenos en khan como con mucha suerte
de poder haber viajado aunque fue muy
difícil logré estar acá y yo creo que es
importante decirlo que la pandemia solo
mostró que los trabajares de la cultura
no tienen ningún tipo de seguridad
social de que es importante que el
gobierno se haga cargo porque el cine
viaje al cine es imagen país el cine es
como nuestro patrimonio y es clave
protegerlos me parece sobre todo en
estos tiempos bueno eres una muy buena
embajadora de chile aquí en cannes
muchas gracias domingo ustedes sigan con
la programación habitual de france tica
[Música]